bei dem was er heute in düsseldorf
vorgelegt wurde handelt es sich um eine
recht unorthodoxe publikation eines
zwischenstandes erforscht wird ein
hotspot rückschlüsse auf ganz
deutschland sind da kaum möglich was ja
auch anerkannt wurde
die ergebnisse wurden dann in einer
pressekonferenz veröffentlicht ohne die
sonst verlangte prüfung durch experten
draußen
deshalb ist es wichtig die ergebnisse
von heinsberg hier von außen zu sehen
zu der kleinen schar von virologen die
mit ihrer forschung weltweit maßstäbe
setzen gehört mindestens ein deutscher
in der aktuellen pandemie ist profession
professor christian drosten von der
berliner charité nicht nur berater der
regierung sondern auch gesicht und
stimme seiner wissenschaft gewordenen
guten abend nach berlin
guten abend herr kleber professor
drosten bringen die ergebnisse von
heinsberg das wissen und auch das
politische verhandeln voran oder nicht
ja erstmal herzlichen glückwunsch an die
kollegen in bonn das ist toll dass so
schnell jetzt ergebnisse schon einmal
vorgelegt wurden und klar natürlich muss
die wissenschaftsgemeinschaft das jetzt
auch erklärt bekommen das heißt wir
brauchen jetzt ganz schnell ein
manuskript dass wir wirklich beurteilen
können so dass wir das design der studie
verstehen
auch die technik von dem verstehen was
dort antesten gemacht wurde und auch die
statistik verstehen die dahinter steckt
gibt es da zweifel dass das einwandfrei
ist es geschah unter ziemlich
schwierigen und schnellen umständen ich
will das gar nicht in zweifel ziehen
aber es ist ja einfach bei jeder
wissenschaftlichen untersuchung so dass
die wissenschaftsgemeinschaft oder
zumindest einen expertenkreis das
beurteilen muss von außen und gerade bei
dieser hohen handlungsanleitung die
jetzt auch von und an die politik
gerichtet wird da muss man so etwas
schon verlangen
nun wurde heute ja verkauft dass es doch
ein bedeutender fortschritt sei dass
endlich mal die dunkelziffer
ausgeleuchtet wurde
man weiß inzwischen dass 15
wirkung jedenfalls in der gegend mit dem
virus bekanntschaft gemacht haben krank
wurden oder es vielleicht auch gar nicht
gemerkt haben
die dunkelziffer ist damit zu beziffern
und zweitens stellt sich heraus dass die
totenzahlen die im moment gefolgert
werden müssen aus den erkenntnissen vom
robert-koch-institut und von der
johns-hopkins-universität weit niedriger
sind als sie dort erscheinen eben weil
die dunkelziffer das umfeld vergrößern
und dann erscheinen sie kleine naja also
da gibt es schon ein paar sachen die man
dazu sagen muss beispielsweise um jetzt
mal mit dem letzten anzufangen
die sterblichkeitsrate also die die
sterblichkeit pro infektionsfall die
wird hier bei 0,37 prozent gesehen und
das ist auch ungefähr ein wert von dem
wir ausgegangen sind in all den vor
überlegungen auch gemeinsam mit
politikern und gruppen von
wissenschaftlern vor ein paar wochen
bevor wir also kontakt sperren in
deutschland eingeführt haben das ist
also nichts neues so ein wert da haben
wir schon vorher auch immer unsere
eigenen korrekturen angestellt und eine
rate von 15 immunität in der bevölkerung
das muss man natürlich zunächst einmal
technisch betrachten ob das diagnosen
sind oder nur signale aus einem
labortest diese labortests haben eine
hohe rate von falsch positiven signalen
rein technisch aber auch weil es
bestimmte erkältungsviren gibt die diese
falschen signale machen in den tests und
da brauchen wir bestätigungs
untersuchungen im labor und im moment
ist das nicht klar ob die gemacht worden
sind also auf solche informationen
warten wir als wissenschaftsgemeinschaft
jetzt schon um das dann auch der politik
zu übersetzen und dann ist natürlich
auch eine andere überlegung die
statistik also beispielsweise die zahlen
sind haben eine ganz andere bedeutung
je nachdem ob mehrere positive befunde
auch in einem haushalt gefunden wurden
oder ob das alles unabhängige patienten
gewesen sind auf dieser pressekonferenz
in düsseldorf heute wurde deutlich dass
jedenfalls das team aus bonn der an
wichtig ist dass die ergebnisse heute
zeigen dass man langsam die tore öffnen
sollte auch um mehr infektionen zu
ermöglichen langsam vorsichtig möglichst
nur bei den fitten und jungen damit man
irgendwann bald zu einem ergebnis kommt
dass 60 prozent der deutschen ungefähr
sich infiziert haben und damit das volk
insgesamt weitgehend immun wird gegen
dieses virus
was halten sie davon ja ich stimme
zunächst einmal den kollegen in einer an
einem grundoptimismus zu dass wir dass
wir doch die wirtschaft wieder in gang
kriegen müssen und natürlich aus diesen
jetzigen maßnahmen raus müssen das sehe
ich ganz genauso
wir müssen uns natürlich aber schon
einmal die grundvoraussetzungen
anschauen von 15 prozent bis auf 70
prozent ist es ein weiter weg da müssen
also sehr viele personen infiziert
werden und das kann man ganz sicher
nicht einfach so durchlaufen lassen
auch ist es so dass bei 15% immunität
wenn das denn technisch so wirklich
stimmt alles und statistisch auch so
stimmt und auch wirklich für deutschland
repräsentativ ist dass man dann
natürlich weiterhin massnahmen braucht
die die geschwindigkeit des ausbruchs
bremsen denn diese 15 prozent bremsen
nicht allzu viel von selbst und diese
maßnahmen müssen aber natürlich auch
viel besser ausgerichtet werden da gibt
es ja jetzt schon erste vorschläge aus
der politik und aus der wissenschaft und
da gibt es auch bestimmte werkzeuge die
auch wirklich hoffen lassen ein
wichtiges werkzeug wird es sein
elektronische hilfsmittel zu verwenden
mobilfunk ups die jetzt derzeit
programmiert werden
die ich für extrem wichtig halte bei
aller datenschutzdiskussion das sind
eben die fein werkzeuge die man braucht
wenn man nicht die groben werkzeuge
gebrauchen will die wir im moment
benutzen eine stimme der skepsis und
vorsicht aus berlin dankeschön
professors
gern
[Musik]